Hello and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host David Flanagan,
although you can find me across the Internet
as Rawkode.
Today we're taking a look at a new
ngrok controller for Kubernetes.
This ngrok controller is different from all the
other ngrok controllers And you'll find out why
in just a few moments. This ngrok controller
is from a company called ngrok.
Yes.
The company that provides a CLI that tunnels
your local development environment onto the Internet for
you to share with anyone you want. They're
now entering the Kubernetes ngrok space and like
I said, it's a little bit different.
So before we dive in to what's different
with ngrok, let's take a look at this
traditional
load balancer approach on EKS,
the managed Kubernetes service from AWS.
First,
we have
some pods and a service. We have the
clustered v one application, which is just a
video of me tapping my watch.
It's exposed currently only within the cluster as
a cluster IP service called clustered v one.
Now if I want to expose this to
the Internet,
I would go to Versus Code,
open the v one YAML,
and change cluster IP
to
a load balancer.
We would then come back and reapply our
configuration
for v one.
Now when we run get service
in the background, AWS has something called a
cloud controller manager. And in fact, this is
true for all cloud providers.
It monitors for load balancer services and provisions
a cloud load balancer. In this case, a
classic load balancer on AWS.
This gives us a domain name that we
can then curl on the right port.
Now these take time. Cloud load balancers typically
take anywhere from two to three minutes before
they'll start serving traffic.
Not only that, they're quite expensive.
So a classic load balancer as provisioned this
way by requesting a load balancer service will
typically run around 18 to $20 per month
per load balancer. So if you go down
this path and do this for all of
your services that you need to expose, you
can end up paying more load balancers than
anything else. And let's not forget, you've also
got to pay the gigabytes of traffic submitted
over the network too. Okay. So let's run
it again. And now we have our exposed
service via the expensive ELB.
But we don't wanna go that route. So
let's revert this to cluster IP
and reapply our v one YAML.
Now I said the ngrok's approach was a
little bit different. So if you want to
learn more, well, watch this video, but also
check out the release blog on ngrok.com.
If you scroll down just a little bit,
you'll find an architecture diagram for how this
works. Now ngrok ngrok controller does not use
in cloud provider load balancer at all, meaning
you don't need to pay for one.
What actually happens is that they have the
ngrok ngrok service, which sits between your cluster
and the Internet.
As your quest comes in, it hits the
ngrok service,
which will tunnel the traffic through to your
ngrok's controller and through to your application.
There's also a little bit of magic sauce,
and that is that when you go through
the ngrok ngrok service,
you can also take advantage of all of
their middlewares.
So on today's demo, we're going to deploy
the ngrok ngrok controller,
attach a middleware for authentication
to protect our application,
and it's gonna be faster than the ELB.
Let's take a look. So let's go back
to code and open ngrok ngrok dot yaml.
Here, we have a standard networking v one
ngrok object where I've set the ngrok class
name to be ngrok.
We have the back end configured to root
everything on slash as a prefix to clustered
v one on the correct port.
However,
we need a host.
So we're gonna go to the ngrok portal
where we can ask for a new domain.
Now everything I'm doing today is on the
ngrok free plan, which gives you access to
one domain.
We paste this in as the host and
remove the ngrok CLI stuff.
Like so. Now I also have a just
file here that has a helm upgrade install
command. This installs the ngrok ngrok ngrok controller.
For more details on how to install the
ngrok controller,
you can go github.com/ngrok/kubernetes-ngrok-controller,
where the instructions to add the repository and
configure the installation are all available.
But for us, we're just going to run
just ngrok to run the helm upgrade command,
which consumes my API token and authentication token
from my environment.
We can now do a kubectl apply
on
my ngrok resource.
Now we can run kubectl get pods
service
ing.
We'll see the ingress controller is running. We
still only have a cluster IP service and
no other load balancer service available,
and our ngrok is here.
So let's head back to the ngrok portal
where we're now on the endpoints page. We'll
give that a quick refresh,
and we now see an endpoint created by
the ngrok ngrok controller.
We can click on this and we see
it's configured to the edge. This just means
that our back end is available for the
app.
So let's click,
and right away, we have the video where
I'll tap on my watch. Now ngrok metalwares
can be configured through this portal too.
If you want to enable MTLS,
you can. TLS termination, sure. Circuit breakers, yes.
Compression,
IP restrictions, OAuth, OIDC, request headers, response headers,
SAML, and webhook verification.
But, of course, we don't want to configure
this through the ngrok UI. As nice as
that is, let's keep this Kubernetes native.
So let's go back to Versus Code where
I have a google.yaml.
Here, we're going to create a custom resource.
This is an ngrok module set. We're gonna
call this Google auth and what we're saying
is enable the auth module, the Google provider,
and only allow access
to this application with the email address david@rawkode.academy.
We can also update our ingress to take
advantage of this module set.
We do this via annotations where we set
case.ngrok.com/modules
and we say apply
Google off.
Now I've called this Google off because it
has a single module, but you can enable
multiple modules
at the same time.
So now we can go back to our
terminal and we can apply
a Google authentication module set.
We can reapply
our ngrok with the new annotation.
So let's head back to the portal and
click on our application again.
This time, we get presented with a Google
OAuth flow using ngrok.com
as OAuth application.
We click login
and there's the video. Let's go to OAuth
and hit refresh. You can see here it's
configured on the back end using a managed
ngrok application.
Of course, if you want to bring your
own OAuth application,
all you need do is add a client
ID and client secret to the CRD.
You can get all the details you need
from kubectl explainngrokmoduleset.modules.0auth.
You can then add to Google and you'll
see everything you need is documented.
So let's just try that again from another
browser.
This time I'll switch to my personal profile
which has a different Google account. We click
login and we get access denied.
So that's pretty sweet. You can expose an
application in Kubernetes with the ngrok ingress controller,
take advantage of their middlewares and avoid load
balance or fees with your cloud provider. So
go check out ngrok ingress and get started
today for free. Go have some fun.